[Music]
and you or someone else and you met
yourself for the first time what would
your first impression like she looks
very arrogant
that's probably what I would think today
I would really like that guy and want to
get to know it I probably wouldn't like
myself that's just how people perceive
me I don't think I'm like that that's
just everyone's first impression of me
and I'm the coolest I ever met to bet
there'd never be anyone like me usually
when people see me they're intimidated
just depends the vibe I give off I guess
I try to be open but you know other
people don't see me that way
childish and immature honestly it is
accurate but I'm like I am mature at
different aspects but I'm like I don't
let people that are not close to me know
that people think I am serious and not
serious reality I am a happy happy
person
I like myself
what I hope it would be what it would be
what it would be
god she's really some right nice guy
this guy's sick
that person makes me
a lot of people tell me
wearily it's not like that
I would probably be called myself
Captain Jack's come back I would think
about myself that I have maybe a little
bit of a high voice but m9 that guy's
definitely smokes weed I would say
that's probably all people think of the
hum here you heard his voice it's only
not true that I suppose for himself this
is what people think I do I'd say she's
probably grew up in the 75 dimepiece is
LG
I'm just small and I I'm sure people
probably think I'm weak but I'm really
not I would be intrigued I am an [ __ ]
because I work at a bar and I'm always
[ __ ] up and people always think that
I'm aggressive that's never the case
that's my true honest answer I smile a
lot guys I dig I'm just kidding I don't
know that's a good question holy [ __ ]
no but I think I'm nice I'm friendly
nice energetic I'm happy easy going I
did some [ __ ] listen I'm a
know-it-all pretty intelligent guy I
don't know everybody has a different
opinion so I mean
whatever your opinion is is your opinion
you know he looks a little disheveled a
little rough around the edges but he
looks like he has a positive aura and
can I smile yeah yeah so yeah I think
that's a good answer at nothing upwards
goal
[Music]